hey everybody welcome to Street Coco
yeah like I'm at the bottoms of my feet
today I've got this shirt on thoughts
Beth okay fair enough maybe every every
stream Coco for now we start with a
little fashion critique oh my god we
turn around bad that's crazy
look at normal business in the front
business in the front right in the back
serious business tonight flat party in
the back hello everyone joke a minute
turn maecius Dakota Kohli perfect
Eclipse
hi y'all do it today we are going to
play a little Wolfenstein the new order
now here's the thing I've been playing
Wolfenstein the new order I know it's an
old game that's okay we're not up in the
trends here we're not into playing the
newest awesomest games although we are
shooting a clueless gamer tonight with a
game that hasn't come out yet we're very
excited about that but so stay tuned
maybe to our snapchat oh yeah yeah
follow team Koko on snapchat to see what
celebrity and what game we're playing
tonight on clueless gamer which you will
see on TV next week I believe but for
right now we're gonna play an old game
it's called Wolfenstein the new order
let's go to it now and here's the thing
I have been playing this one level I
swear to god for like a week we're on
the moon if you don't know about
Wolfenstein the new order here's the
deal sir hi sky says well everyone is
Planetree play at the moment that's true
you're killing Nazis it's great it's
super fun it's brutal
it's by the guys who made doom it's
really great but I'm stuck on the moon
killing Nazis on the moon killing Nazis
on the moon is what we're doing today
with laser guns and I'm stuck on this
one level and I'm gonna need your help
to get past it so this whole hour might
just be us playing one level yeah so I
think what we should do is we're gonna
start the old blade death count and
we'll just keep track of how many deaths
but how many times do you think I'm
gonna die this this in this hour I want
everybody's prediction on how many times
you think I'm gonna die because let me
just tell you it's gonna be a lot twenty
it seems low thank you for that vote of
confidence do
says Kelly Nazis on the moon with lasers
murica exactly let's get into it baby
let's do it alright so here's the deal
now if you know anything about me
you know that I love stabbing people in
the butt which we're gonna do right now
oh no we stabbed in the neck okay fair
enough now we got a little armor here
now this takes place this game takes
place in an alternate world kind of man
on the high castle
esque of 139 says james o'keefe
Jesus that's so much death I mean iliyan
that's that seems like a lot that seems
a little high but you know what you
haven't seen how hard this level is yet
so basically this - signal detected is
up in the corner up in that corner over
there you have to kill the two generals
before they sound the alarm now this is
hard to do in a big round room where
there's nothing to hide behind
thirty-six seventeen twenty four eight
eight hundred thousand come on Armand
now if we had a knife we had an hour and
a half I would say absolutely we do not
mind actually making the the YouTube
chat just a little bigger for me ah can
you get a deathcounter dizzy death sure
when the death when a death starts when
the death starts here's a dude he says
odd so we're gonna stab him right in the
crotch yeah that's gonna so I might
reach eight hundred thousand so guys
everybody pay attention now maybe I
should go mounted gun here I kind of
feel like maybe no can I sneak up on
this dude by the way I'm already doing
way better than I normally do
I'm real nervous
Kelly Nazis waffle tarts this would be
Wolfenstein the new order now I'm
excited for Wolfenstein the new Colossus
to come out patience you know it's all
about patience guys but Stabbin no head
step there is a great move that where
you just slice them right in the butt
it's a great it's pretty awesome yeah I
would be into that
did you guys by the way speaking of
butts slicing I don't want to get too
gross here but we are killing Nazis on
the moon oh and apparently there was
this Russian couple they caught that was
killing and eating people for like 16
years you hear about that no they just
caught him just bringing that up not
that I want to eat these now don't want
to eat these Nazis but I'm just saying
you know yeah I'm glad they work up non
sequitur that what gotcha yes yes
blair-taylor it's based on alternate
alternate history where and you're
you're like sergeant blaster wits I mean
there's a fair amount of humor to this
game as you'll see when I start dying a
billion times what do we think the move
is here we think the movies just go down
the stairs here great topic place asthma
suits look it's a misfire what do you
want
someone's out there at school right now
and actually this is like homework there
we go exactly this isn't the right but
this is this is not real not I mean this
is alternate history Nazis really didn't
go to the moon guys no one ever went to
oh stop it
what are you Stanley Kubrick oh man this
would be great if I could kill this dude
but stab him I missed him in the butt I
did knock him out I love how much I
built this up and did I just beat this
level you guys definitely oh my god wait
I will say I haven't I've spent an
entire week on this and it's never
happened well this is great all right
well let's go kill more Nazis you know I
feel like in any game you kind of get to
the moon and that's kind of like the
last the last couple levels you know I'm
spacesuit uh one of these is my map here
we go
oh I got to go this way by the way all
these moon guns suck I'm just putting
that out there they all suck really hard
no it's on almost easy Madeleine since
this I'll try to go easier on the stream
play I was harsh on Sunday yeah I was
streaming on my own on Sunday and
Madeline was lighting me up I didn't
appreciate it Madeline but you know what
it was well deserved because I was
terrible ooh by the way a big part of
this game and I'm not even kidding is
welding yeah it's like cutting through
things which is like the dumbest thing
ever it's the greatest way to take an
amazing fun game and make it not fun
guess what kids now what is this farming
simulator no is this welding simulator
come on hey deaf night what's up five I
believe in used to say Garcia well thank
you dude I believe in you I believe in
Harvey Dent you change your mind 45
times all right well we're past the part
where I could have died a lot so maybe
it's gonna be zero
times guys spoiler alert it's not gonna
be zero times what's a mate greatest
waste also I'll see that oh that's a big
scary thing I don't want to it's cool
more welding so you guys thought I was
lying about the welding thing not lying
by the way that's super loud and it has
to smell so this is a terrible thing to
do
oh I have to go through here that's
interesting oh come on dude ah this game
is the worst there's also a dude
sleeping Oh
oh he broadcasted too dumb oh yeah
thanks God you know I bring it I bring
it for the team Coco's dream what them
that's me Oh totally it also turns into
a gun
[Music]
I think they're throwing grenades in
there which is sucks all I want is like
a normal gun with the boys that thing is
real scary I'm gonna hide in the
bathroom which I normally do on dates so
this is working out okay do you mind
scrolling down the YouTube chat they're
cool blown up shot him in the dick
always aim for the dick I say you know
it teaches the other guys not to come
near you that sucks
[Music]
moon guns are the worst guys remember
when you go to the go to the moon bring
your own gun
[Music]
god damn it these stupid moon guns don't
do anything we'll run away this is on
the old ps4 yep that's what I like doing
recharging your phone and your gun desk
German engineering I don't know what I'm
playing on I'm playing on super heart
hey open gamer what's up coolest dad
gamer bad craftsman always blamed their
tools well that's me bad craftsman bad
craftsman of death hi II got him ah
Jesus let's see you knives still work on
the moon guys in case anybody was
wondering I don't know see me more pizza
this a-hole make sure I get him right in
a dick it's important to me oh god no
fun oh look what I got
alright headshots with a win
regeneration a well-designed game yeah
it happens it doesn't happen or what I
don't know maybe there's a bug all right
where we going it's my next guys I'm
doing really well I want everyone to
just know that I'm turning it on for you
guys I love you and I want you to know
there's always a handful of crappy guns
in space game I guess you're right
halo though I think had a lot of great
guns right the needler I mean come on
halo is groundbreaking cool I have one
shot just like Eminem and that song do
not miss your chance to blow right guys
anyone know it spaghetti monster Getti
uh what am i doing down here now here we
go
I feel like uh
this sucks low on ammo
like going here I found out where all
the Nazis develop their pictures
everybody any consideration bringing
Conan to twitchcon what is twitchcon
amorphous can't go in there
ah when is twitchcon this does feel very
golden I asked actually I was talking to
somebody today
who's replaying Goldeneye and I was
saying like it's interesting because
those games like right now I I think we
really take for granted the language of
games like how like the cone of
awareness it's a maple and things like
that and like sneaking around these
things but with gold and I we will we
were still kind of learning about that
so it's very imperfect like you get
you're sneaking is like ridiculously
hard it doesn't
here they come I'm hurting real bad
oh thanks blasts zombie Jordyn spaghetti
shoot - name cuz I think living with a
limp for the rest of your life it's
about the kind of punishment this guy
deserves where is he
I know you're out here buddy really you
some health at this point there is
health anywhere
we've got anybody want to give me some
health yeah so tonight's a werewolf
assign game is regenerating health it's
basically our key she were like doom at
least that's what I thought it was I
will say one thing that's great
like playing doom and then playing this
game with the improved upon and doom is
the thing and somebody on reddit was
talking about this which I completely
agree with in this game
in most first-person shooters when you
get low on life you want to run away and
you want to try to find help in doom you
get like when you get low on life the
way to get more life is just to murder
more demons so you actually get makes
you more aggressive which is like a
really cool step up also I think they
the other thing I think they did really
well in doom like this is a great system
but it doesn't work so well on
Wolfenstein that works you really want
to it's not as good weapon select system
but if they really perfected it for Doom
so I could see myself dying here a lot
but slice yes we slice them in the plot
oh it's my favorite guys it makes this
game worth it you know little bun little
bun slice used to my AOL screen name but
slice 78 now somebody's taking it I bet
well gold face mask for no reason cool
there's anything I know about Nazi
technology it's a lot of big cables and
weird pipes this mission is based the
iron sky in video game form what's iron
sky is that one of the Game of Thrones
novels winds of winter iron sky red
wedding santa's revenge I don't know
I've read a lot of those I've only read
the first couple game things I don't
know is there a guy named Santa there
should be I will say one of the cool
things about do we have time to do any
welding buff what do you think yep good
answer that's the answer I was looking
for wasting my bullets doing some
welding
yep that was worth it not at all um
there's that there's a captain jerkface
but slice I wish you could pick what
part see that's fine but to really just
like slice them in the butt guys I just
Twitter search but slice and surprising
a lot of people are using it as an
insult yeah probably because they played
Wolfenstein guys big deal great movie
but slice o
iron sky is not seized from the moon
invading Earth is that like a theory or
is that like a movie or what straighten
yeah skinemax iron sky ooh there we go
hi get into the butt Oh fine on the
chest oh my god you know man
you would think the resistance would
have one other person that could help
them besides me like that's it just
blast awaits he's doing it all for the
nookie by the way like a lip biscuit
song there's a lady I don't mean to
spoil anything guys but there's some
cutscenes in here that are pretty risky
of kissing so it's definitely PG ten is
that a thing PG ten because it's like 13
it's not pg-13 but you know 10 year-olds
probably shouldn't see it I don't know
Madelyn the welding so loud don't be
critical I thought you weren't gonna be
critical this dream trance guy - we're
making but slice the thing right now you
got that right justice sip syphilis
syphilis I'm not sure how to say your
name
also I'll say these games I always get
nervous when they give you a lot of
health and armor because you're about to
go into a really bad area me and my four
bullets a lot of computers in here I
think there's time for a quick game of
League of Legends game starts in the
late 40s but this part is in the 60s
that's correct
don't get cocky nerds is less blinking
lights that says computers in the 60s
guys yeah sure gotta charge my gun
I forgot the cord at home would that be
embarrassing yeah you need to charge a
gun in a life-or-death situation but it
it uses mini it uses light instead of
micro you know
[Music]
maybe I'll take it off the welding I
might have to do some last-minute
life-or-death welding guys I go in here
jump into this thing sure went out
crouching the game why am I not spinning
at the ground yeah oh yeah the Nazis won
though our dude a futurist attempt we
didn't find out why that feature is
detected we cool by the way recordings I
don't care I'm not gonna listen to him
sorry I'm just not gonna do it although
we'll say what they were pretty dope and
in BioShock some great recordings that
was kind of the whole game can't wait
for the second game good can't wait for
the second game either oh there's a
reason for their technological
advancement I don't want to spoil you I
can't wait I'm guessing aliens isn't
that just all technological advancement
is just from aliens I'd like to see a
game where the aliens are less
technologically advanced than us you
know like I did like district 9 because
for that exact reason because they
weren't you know they had like crazy
stuff but like nobody really knew how to
it's that thing nobody really knew how
to use it and not all the aliens were
super smart and awesome a lot of them
were just like weird bugs here we go
I'm telling you this has got to be like
the last level right
I've become what about this is just a
prequel to Darth Vader yeah I beat this
before it good for you I should oh
thanks chili flavor you're my favorite
actually cherry is one of my favorite
flavors and I don't really like sweet
things what am I going a lot of question
marks here okay what let's go through an
adventure something oh it's not aliens
interesting all right good I hope it's
not aliens cuz that's lazy its Einstein
he gave them all to the there we go this
is what you want
nice big pointless door here man
yeah sweet dude this is dope this place
obviously has giant gerbils giant space
gerbils guys yeah I'm pretty I'm pretty
Darth up pretty Vader doubt right now
this is fun
what about if this just turns into
Skyrim the Moon Edition tube city I
haven't seen any of the I'm sorry I
don't know what you're talking about
city to city Beth is the cool in here we
all know it no I hate these things
this is very Star Wars this is very cool
I'm running away from these things slay
them
whoa I could jump crazy
it says the guy in the moon idiot I'm
gonna go down here yes I can can I go
inside somewhere uh I'm not going I just
hide from those things oh god don't
oh that was dumb that was dumb that was
dumb I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm
dying I'm dead I'm dead
well death count 1 1 that's pretty good
guys it took me a half hour to die
that's awesome I did like a realistic no
sound morphus I agree people we gotta
stop Michael people are giving you the
to City shoutout
thanks miss tits what do you say to that
Madeline Sims that's right
I'm better than you thought no wait
where are we going here let's do a
little Oh
just forward into the right can I skip
um jump down here
it's a gold meteor rock cool oh did they
find me you know what there's way better
ways to have patrolling drones
first of all just have motion detectors
with guns you know if you have a moon
base and you need it defended guys just
come to me because I know a shitload
about defending moon stuff
clearly check the map I mean totally the
wrong place oh I'm supposed to jump over
here I think ya know their button to
push for no reason got it no one would
ever design a moon base like this but
I'm not gonna be a dick about it
says the guy was just a dick about it
wearing this shirt oh electric city's
better than tube city was that another
Michael Scott invention oh I see I see
you know one thing I think that probably
sucks about being an astronaut you can't
get your beats by dre headphones in the
thing you know yeah I got some cool
beats by dre headphones recently and
although I hate that you have to charge
them up like [ __ ] you dude or they won't
work that's like the most [ __ ] thing
I've ever heard of in my life
I will say they're comfy they're
comfortable and they sound great but I
can't fit them in my helmet when I go on
space so that's super annoying
so dre bro hook your boy up with some
moon headphones scalpel what am i doing
I just commit suicide at the end but me
and everything that must be done
otherwise there's no no I hate this
[ __ ] by the way question oh you are
believing
she did we killed by the way we killed
her before with one of those things with
that things oh this is dark what's about
to happen
oh don't eat that sucks yeah
now Uncle Kracker it's not sexist she's
just a terrible Oh this is important
we're gonna get rid of this number
ouch
now she was an enemy the blond-haired
woman was an enemy we killed her twice
so far and she came back I ripped her
off it was awesome it was really cool I
just killed the [ __ ] out of her it was
really great but maybe she's gonna come
back maybe it's a little bit of
foreshadowing guys yeah oh right cuz
they got nukes on the move and I forgot
as you do not sure why do you want to
put nukes in the moon got it we're all
maxed out I do like those words
sneaky is the name of the game snake
snake snake it's sexist that I know it's
sexist okay it's sexist guys I'm sorry
but she's a Nazi so she's the worst
keeping a knife in a sink that's where I
keep my combat knife is this one of
those games you can get through with
without killing anybody that might be
interesting you know like there's that
whole movement of people who are
pacifists in games there's this game I
dunno I've been playing called bleed
which is really cool it's like this kind
of 8-bit shooter where you're this like
badass girl who's like just shoots
everybody and she's dope but it looks
kind of like Scott Pilgrim a little bit
like that it's very cool oh god I'm
gonna go hide a little this is not a
good place to hide
and it's a game where let's go up the
stairs pal let's go up the stairs should
wake up the stairs can we please go up
the stairs can we go up the stairs
alright great because a little bug I
couldn't go up the stairs now I gotta
stab this dude I don't get the but slice
anybody
that guy sucks oh brother well right in
the dick
wow that guy's pretty shot up huh these
moon guns though I'm telling you it
looks like they do a good job but
they're really not great as far as moon
guys yeah everybody's talking at me I
don't know what they're saying I should
watch mother I do want to see what the
final boss is Frau Pei tree is that the
woman the final boss is the woman oh man
I tore her ass apart though with a giant
robot
probably
oh you know what I bet she is guys
please not shoot me I'm recharging my
phone oh god the fact there's only two
guns on the moon so annoying if you want
your dick shot come around the corner
cuz I'm happy to give it to you Beth
could you ask Aaron to play fifa 18 once
I'll play some feet 18 I'll play some
thief 18 any more dudes around here
I killed the head dude so they shouldn't
be any uh-oh whoa that's a bad guy
definitely running away from this dude
well let's shoot him with our welder gun
which seems to work well which seems to
work well thank you
this guy
come on dude ah hate this guy eating's
I'm a slicing the but just because good
I know I can't get through the armor but
it's worth it to me
take take it sorry guys good you see
that side of me but you know what I'm a
man just like you guys and I get upset
and frustrated just like you guys do
these weapons upgrade I don't know bear
ski how do we upgrade these weapons
somebody tell me something about this
game I don't know [ __ ] well now we're in
here better recharge my stuff cuz that's
the world I'm in now got a recharge
after every single guy ah man you know
what I need these needs like a mobi case
you know these guns need like oh you
know we should do is we should get in
the business of in the Wolfenstein world
opening a business where you could put
your gun in a case and it recharges it
for you you know alien games game fists
in the new alien guns always suck I
agree okay
all I gotta say is that question mark
better be some kind of boss cuz we got
20 minutes left and your boy is real
sick of being on the moon do I go back
to Earth at some point am I just like on
the moon now forever is that just like
I'm on the moon and this is it you know
what I bet in this game we're gonna like
sacrifice ourselves or something you
know don't you think it has that kind of
smell to it
this game real sacrificial yeah game am
I going I'm going number right what's
the right kind of straight to the right
but I can't go straight to the right
because this thing is here and this is
no worky this gnome a quirky oh this is
where we came in
some games Mars no can't be
oh we did this I did this whole section
already I kill all these dudes teabag
him I can't yeah he was face down I
couldn't teabag him I would've though if
I could have but I think you know what
I'm gonna say something teabagging is so
2015 guys really but slicing is where
it's at you know that's where you want
to be but oh wait 20 18 foot welding
yeah I'm into that let's do it let's
start the butt welding movement where
you weld their butt cheeks together and
then they're just they die a slow
agonizing death that actually sounds
pretty terrible yeah it's pretty gnarly
here we go
someone said you're 75 to 80% Jesus
Ramona's diary I'm not gonna listen to
it because I don't think it's
appropriate to sneak and listen to
people's Diaries oh look my awesome gun
disappeared because I could have
actually used it here cool
Oh God how many goddamn levels am I
gonna have to sneak around here I'm the
worst I will say just provide me a
little the moon this game has gotten
pretty stale since I've got another moon
I don't mean you [ __ ] on it but it's
it's pretty boring since we've reached
the moon I'm just gonna put it out there
it's like four levels of the same thing
[Music]
and I know it's all dramatic and stuff
but come on
I don't think we're gonna be able to but
slice it but I'll definitely stab
there should be like a front butt slice
you know who said on huh
don't shoot
I'm Dale no I'm up here yeah
now Jesus Christ that's a big robot dog
TV stars
getting lit up gotta kill all the dudes
that couldn't have been all I guess I
was all right that just means there's
gonna be a big evil dude down here
somewhere I think my gut says hello Beth
and Aaron the weirdo now what would you
call home why would you call me weirdo
because this shirt I would agree with
you this is a terrible weird ass shirt
I'll take this thank you
health anything around here anything
help me humble use some help please
cyber natural-looking Conan possibly be
doing right now that's more important
than that's nothing dude nothing he's
just scared he's scared to come down
here and face these moon Nazis I mean
who wouldn't be scared you know their
moon Nazis what do you want they're
Nazis they're on the moon they're moon
Nazis I get down there at some point I
like it oh I see oh my god
just say imagine if you had to come to
work in this place every day it's so
depressing look at this yeah not that
coal it's a lot of hard corners and
depressing lighting very oppressive
lighting down we go more levels that
don't mean it hey I can't oh I came up
this level I guess
cool cool he says without meaning it
we're supposed to go here out that way
up there alright I think they were just
like let's make this game longer here's
a couple of dumb levels you know wait
guys we made this awesome game but it's
way too short let's just put in a bunch
of levels that nobody cares about
they don't advance the plot in any way
there we go they're hard to navigate and
we won't let Aaron but slice as many
people as they want Conan is missing the
blood slice they actually I will say
that we got coconut get it no I stop
I'll promise okay come here nut you know
you keep just whispering things of me
and it doesn't they're all just the same
[ __ ] it's the same
none of this is different it's all the
same thing with the same dudes and the
same dumb guns give me back to earth
when the guns are cool they blow [ __ ] up
you have to charge them every two
minutes
no dudes around that means it's gonna be
a big bad guy all right my words I'm
telling you about right now
well 15 minutes we're still on the moon
I don't know if we're getting through
compression Who am I there's
Toxic Avenger you're right oh here we go
I do have a cool leather jacket on
though man right maybe I go is this guy
for Halloween I'm printing to encrypt
your keys now I'm pretty much Southwest
Airline Passage to get back to earth
here come the dogs yeah
oh we got to escape how are we ever
gonna do it boy I hope I make it out of
here guys alarms very otter says his
outfit doesn't see me on plus alpha
security breach uh we got more we got
more entries from run his diary I hope
she's dating someone new well there's
nothing great let's just get off them
can we just get out of the moon I hate
the moon man told moon situation has
been a real buzzkill no boner killer
this makes me never want to have a robot
dog because they're dicks
yeah
but slice and no God D me boy wants is a
nice little but slice for Christmas you
know mom if you're watching please stuff
my stocking with buzz slices and I don't
mean slices of but I mean opportunities
for me to slice my buds because that's
what I'm looking for
cuz I ain't get it from this game all
right where we going
o more welding I forgot I knew it'd have
been five minutes this weed welded
something there we go cool you know what
when I just charged this little bad boy
up this is the team cup of cocoa
bobsledding Jersey you're right
phantasm I am a fan of this game just
not the Murray part this game is super
fun but since we put on the moon it's so
boring it's like how can you make the
moon boring the more and the moon is
exciting and crazy okay actually the
moon is a dead lifeless husk hanging in
the sky
you did gotcha right knit I shot you in
the face bro it's nice but it's a good
didn't waste money on the mask as
money's worth down there maybe no one
knows no one knows how you got here
I guess they don't really care about
alpha security breaches cuz no one is
coming after me yeah that's like alpha
security breach
I've seen three dudes
it's not Imperial storm armor that's
true why is this George slansky playing
Wolfenstein because Jordan doesn't play
video games Jordan thinks life isn't
real
ah man all right no kidney slice up
should we weld this or just go bad I
knew Beth was gonna say well but you're
a fan of welding just in your day to day
life you enjoy is that true what did you
well
wait really yeah oh my god this is a
chrome welder welded welded on still
can't see it's telling me I need to get
a we're gonna do
don't always bullets you know so I have
to like find a spacesuit I guess now or
get in here and do something throw
waiting for the beat a security breach
oh soldering and welding oh yeah you
soldered we go says you were soldering
no one I don't look at this
well yeah and she welded bars of iron
look guys hey we're in the big tube city
did we made it city
I think their tram is broken wait now
I'm trapped in here and there's no way
out
wait I'm not gonna have any breasts this
is gonna suck keep saying tell that to
fish I don't know what I'm saying
ten minutes all these moon rocks is
making me oh whoops
sorry pal
sorry we deserve that right in the dick
shoot him in the dick
Aaron Blair with his hit shoot him in
the dick well no place to charge my [ __ ]
up oh wait here it is I'm just gonna get
a quick ten minutes to charge up my
phone Moon mad nice space madness cool
space escalator make sense hi guys nice
to see you
alright the dick that's my trademark I
want people to know I was here
Beth welder no well always well even an
alpha alpha security breach Beth Ann I
find time to do a little welding because
you like it
I know somebody was shooting in me I saw
them
I got to go back and charge my goddamn
gun office games the worst who came up
with this idea to charge your [ __ ] I
want names I want names of who it's the
most artificial way to make things
difficult just design a better level
dude design a better level don't make me
just go and [ __ ] constantly recharge
[ __ ] all right here we go
back out the way we came right ie I'm
gonna need some cover here kids
this guy big fat laser gun in the face
Oh cute you're cute you're cute you're
cute cuz I didn't shoot his whole dick
off just part of it
anybody back here you want to say
anything now alright are we going I need
to charge my [ __ ] gun again Ivan
Trott trust me I've been trying oh now
we're out here and I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die this is definitely a place for
I'm gonna die
it's the woman right saying the thing
welder no weld Beth
damnit now listen if I have to start
over before this this is gonna be a
problem because we got five minutes left
and I'm gonna kill the [ __ ] out of this
guy in the five minutes I only shot off
half his dick ken has burritos
Nazis with frickin laser beams uh okay
here we go
yeah oh you know what we forgot to go
we're just gonna get some armor real
quick before we go and murder this dude
in the other room that way we'd have to
do so much welding all right dude we're
gonna go kill the guy who always makes
his deliveries so he doesn't make his
delivery it's gonna be great hey wait a
second
now I'm all turned around so I need to
kill all these dudes I thought they
weren't there I can save you
sneaky sneaky pie
well done oh well we do have time oh
you're right we only five minutes but
still we got a seat
always said this is it guys we're gonna
beat this oh there's nothing in there
we got burned by your love of welding oh
that
oh that's we were gonna weld and then it
didn't it didn't work for us all right
well it's charge of our [ __ ] let's go
kill this guy
it should just charge up all your guns
what the [ __ ] it's so it's what a dumb
mechanic all right here we go
why ahead shall we it's the dick I'm
trying to shoot them in the dick not the
legs all right where's he at
come on I know you're out here you
always make your deliveries let's go you
coming out of somewhere or what
coming out of somewheres yet
other Hisss
I think I went better for us than him
but maybe I'm lying oh there's two of
them cool
gotta charge my gun real quick
the idea is cool died I think we're done
that's it we did we dead we can't do it
I'm tired I can't stand any more of
these moon Nazis they're trying to mean
that yeah exactly you know what I think
we would have kept playing if that last
box
we have welded open and given us
something great instead it was a hollow
promise of welding which is really what
moon Nazis are all about a bunch of
[ __ ] ah guys uh yeah the developers
didn't expect the player to cross the
entire level shooting people in the legs
it's the dick I'm shooting them in the
dick get it right sometimes the legs get
hit but it's I'm not going for the legs
guys thank you for joining us for the
stream Coco no later today we're gonna
be doing a live stream Q&A with the
fellas from Impractical Jokers who are
amazing and super fun that's gonna be at
a Facebook so today stay tuned for that
around 3:15 ish PT PT 314 is PT so
that's an about I'm the saying about two
and a half hours ish right 2nf hours ish
stay tuned for that you can get your
questions in for the fellas of
Impractical Jokers and make sure you
watch tonight's show which is gonna be
fantastic and tonight we have a secret a
secret that's right
although Tom Cruise is it which is great
it's secret vote so watch for that
tonight tonight's show then of course
stay tuned to our snapchat team at Team
Coco because you'll get a sneak peek of
the amazing gamer clueless gamer we're
shooting this evening which will not be
airing until next week so you'll see
who's gonna be in it and what game it's
gonna be yeah it's gonna be fantastic
it's super fun and exciting and I will
not be wearing this shirt which is
probably the best part of all thank you
guys for joining us with stream Coco
it's been a blast we've playing
Wolfenstein the new order and we love
you all see you guys next week or see
you later tonight a couple hours on
Facebook
you